[Musique]
on l'appelle hirondelles du faubourg
c'était une pauvre fille d'amour
mais un jour la saison printanière
une petite ouvrière comme les hôtels
auraient bien tourné c'est son père au
lieu de l'abandonner
abc protéger d'un slot l'hirondelle
[Musique]
elle l'émission vous êtes la dernière
chanteuse des rues oui monsieur vous
allez arrêter il ya combien de temps
maintenant il ya assez longtemps parce
que maintenant c'est le plus possible de
chanter dans la rue
à ce moment là on ne peut plus vendre
mon format et les formats c'est quoi les
formats c'était les petites chances les
petites chansonnettes été imprimés c'est
ce que vous avez saccagé dans la main et
nous allons les chercher rue du vertbois
à ce moment là alors on en achetait par
100 ou 200 ou 300 et nous allons dès
diffusé dans paris ou dans toutes les
stations de métro
voici le printemps en la douceur du
temps nous fait des avances
si vous avez connu l'époque des
chanteurs de rue comment ça se passait à
cette époque là il y avait les chanteurs
au coin des rues comme ça quand les gens
c'est trop c'est trop tôt touré puis à
tout moment
enfin oui il y a même dépendante et en
jeter de l'argent je sentais le
dénicheur le petit vin blanc le petit
vin blanc était vraiment diffusé à la
rue à ce moment là parce qu on était
trente groupes à ce moment-là de chanter
les chances il y avait trente groupes de
chanteurs de termites et comment ça se
passait alors il ya eu une concurrence
une rivalité entre ces groupes de
chanteurs va c'est à dire contre ça
dépend des défend faisait les marchés à
laon se trouvaient deux groupes ont
établi de se mélanger à ce moment là
parce qu'autrement n'aurait pas
travailler ni d'un côté ni vous
choisissiez vous même vos emplacements
pour chanter non c'est à dire que
lorsque nous allions à la préfecture de
police
on avait une boîte et on tirait des
numéros un bon l'attribution des
emplacements se faisait par tirage au
sort tirage au sort alors celui qui
avait tiré le numéro 1 choisi c'est la
meilleure place de paris essence était
la meilleure pour moi ça a été la
madeleine ligne 10 c'est le métro c'est
là car au chaud rien qu'à pour un
bouquet de viana
lily c'est toujours pour un mot d'amour
un peu de folie dans la tête
[Musique]